I'm arguing with my health and wellness
that my team and I have built an
algorithm that takes better care of me
than I can myself it is able to look at
all the data in my body it's looking at
scientific evidence it creates an
algorithm so it creates Superior
cognitive ability Superior metabolic
ability Superior physical ability All
Above I am a superior human because it's
algorithm so I have two options do I say
I'm going to do things I did and go Prov
my pantry am I going to make decisions
on the menu no like I'm going to choose
the algorithm just like I use GPS like a
washing machine and like I use autopilot
on airplane and so it's inevitable that
when these things cross the
technological threshold and they allow
each of us to achieve our goals we adopt
them instantaneously up until that point
we kick and scream we talk about lost
jobs we talk about the fear like it's a
process every single time it happens but
we ruthlessly adopt them and so that's
just what's going to happen it's
absolutely
inevitable